i'm with beth ross singing coach vocal
coach vocal
expert i don't know what to call you
yeah um
we're gonna record like one line of me
singing to send off to a producer to see
if they can if they can fix my voice and
give them a very the best chance
possible in order to create something
very beautiful yes and also so we saw
you so we've got me singing badly on
camera as well but the plan is that
we're gonna have uh someone look at look
at the thing i record and try and auto
tune and produce it to
to do what apparently every youtuber is
doing and start a singing career i'm not
going to start a singing career he might
start singing i'm not going to start a
singing career
he's going to start a singing career
so very first thing
like i should i should probably
admit how i sing without any training or
production yeah so let's let's first
line of our holy night i'm only doing
like the first couple lines that's this
all right here we go
yes i'm not exactly hitting that yeah
okay
oh holy night
the stars are brightly shining
i missed that shining i missed that
honestly i you're so is so funny you can
it's not that bad because i don't i feel
i don't feel like i'm i'm confident at
all with it like i feel like i'm part of
that's because there's four cameras
running and everything like that but i i
it feels like
i
am too tense it feels like i am
shouting
in a in a church
yeah okay no pun intended giving it a
chris christmas song but like it feels
like i'm suddenly barging in something
going ah
well look i feel like a lot of it for
you is gonna actually be the confidence
yeah because
your voice is a good voice like i'm
really telling you that your voice is a
good voice thank you like so many people
come into singing lessons and they're
on that first lesson you are way past
most first
i'm not joking okay
you've got resonance people struggle
with resonance your pitching is great i
also struggle with receiving compliments
it turns out so thank you that's that's
that's lovely let's start with the
warm-up okay we'll see what's going on
with your voice all right
okay so
we're gonna do just a little scale
you're gonna be down the octave so
you're gonna be down here for me so
we're
literally perfectly on pitch i told you
that was great yeah okay you know what i
heard this thing i feel like i feel like
i'm being flattered here no
no okay like literally um that's like
the hardest thing everyone as well when
you freak out at the first that first
chord that i play everyone goes like and
then it all goes off so you just yes i
know my cat my karaoke is not great my
karaoke is great in about that range and
as soon as you get like outside that
octave it starts to fall apart well
that's normal because that's around your
speaking range okay so you're exercising
that every single day right and then
when you get outside of your speaking
range everyone goes like oh what did we
do yeah if you go a couple octaves up
with that it's going to fall apart well
let's see we'll see what happens okay so
we're going to go one step up mumma
this is great
good from here
mama
i felt like i lost that halfway through
but okay you just pushed it a little bit
but we'll talk about this in a second i
don't know what that means exactly we'll
talk about it let's try here
mama
[Music]
so the
the take-home key that i want you to
feel about singing is that the effort
you put in does not equal
a better output okay which is good i
like not putting everything yeah you
want to be really i'm so physically
nervous like i'm going like this i'm
just i'm deeply uncomfortable with it
yes it's okay it's okay everyone always
is especially like the first time you're
singing in front of someone that you've
never sung in front of before the
internet
it's not a nice
okay okay but you're doing really good
so
all i want you to do in fact what you
have so good is you've got so much
resonance and
i actually trained that that was
deliberate like i went many many years
ago doing university radio i like i got
to uni i was like about 18 and my voice
was
very much in the front of my mouth about
here and everything sort of just up here
and it wasn't really and then i sort of
trained it over the years to go down and
back yes yeah it's so resonant and
that's great so um this we'll go to this
one again
and as you get to the top one at the
moment you're kind of reaching up to
that top one as if it's like a triangle
i want you to think of it all on the
same plane you're not putting any more
effort to the top one than you're on the
bottom one
okay let's give that a go
[Music]
okay let's try something give me like a
dopey bear whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa
see how much easier that is yes why is
that easier there's a couple of reasons
you're creating a big space inside your
mouth so your mouth is a resonance
chamber you i always think of it like um
like a trumpet if you just heard your
voice box by itself your airs moving
through the voice box through the vocal
chords they vibrate and that creates a
sound yes as we go higher it's just an
extension of your speaking voice you
don't need to do anything madly
different you can speak you're doing
great all right
so let's go to this um where we worked
we were coming
so we're going to try a note up here
we're just doing a little mama ma
and this is a tricky part of our voice
because this is a transition between
your chest voice and your head voice now
it's tricky because there's an actual
anatomical shift happening here in your
chest voices muscles inside the vocal
cords at the back of the vocal cords
that are responsible for tightening and
relaxing them okay um so when you
tighten your vocal cords you know it
gets higher and when you relax it gets
lower yep when you go into your head
voice the whole larynx tilts forward a
little bit there's muscles on the front
okay um so if you were being 100
anatomically head voiced which never
actually happens but if it was it would
just be using that tilt all right if it
wasn't if it's 100 anatomically chest
voice just using the muscles on the
inside the vocal cords and at the back
okay mix there's this middle ground
where you're using these muscles in
combination and it gets a little bit
tricky yeah i can feel it sort of i
don't know it feels like something's
moving well probably
the as you get higher that resonance is
probably going to move up your body and
that's okay so that's where the idea of
head voice and chest voice comes from
right essentially comes from most
singers because everyone feels a little
bit differently most feelers feel chest
voice in their chest and most singers
feel head voice in their head okay
actually can you give me a whoo-hoo
yeah that's entirely up here yeah okay
and then again it's one of those things
that people feel like oh as i get higher
i have to do something totally crazy
this is my stupid catch phrase but if
you can who it you can sing it right
right if you come back who that now you
got it okay give me like
that note
cool can you make it like how you can
feel it as far back as you can on your
head no no only only by dropping an
octave no you didn't you didn't do it
that felt like i did ah you just made it
more resonant that's interesting
it's not the same note
it is the same note yeah this is
interesting because that placement
changes
the tone of the note and that can be
confusing because what you've got
you're a note but actually a note isn't
just one note you're not hearing one
note you're hearing all the frequencies
on top of it so actually instead of
changing the note you're just adding
more lower frequencies by bringing it
back okay and by making it thinner and
forward you're um
boosting higher frequencies
okay so so it's the same octave but
we're hearing it's like it's been eq'd
yeah okay cool and that's the amazing
thing about voice you can kind of eq
your own voice as you go okay um now you
know we can get help at the studio but
also we can do that we're gonna need it
but all right let's let's
yeah so
[Music]
that fifth was completely wrong doesn't
matter i was trying that that was really
good
[Music]
okay can you feel that how that
concerned about that tilting backwards
absolutely think of that forward thing
again
[Music]
okay so on the way up this is that
transition between head and chest yes
and it is like this for every single
person and by the way we're way higher
than all holy nights so you're gonna
have no problems you might just need to
raise yourself pilot a bit if that is
something that you can
it's been a while i remember having to
do stuff like that when we're doing
production in phonetics and i was never
really good at it but all right let's
try it okay so think of that there
you can do it on your own
ah no miss the first note
ma no one more time
[Music]
ah
that mist all over the place yeah but no
you drink it you're doing good okay give
me the woo on that and keep shimmying
give me the nose again
whoa
okay so you went after your head voice
perfect once it was up there it felt
fine but that transition cracked so
badly one more time
[Music]
okay there you go
it's not falsetto it's just all up here
isn't it well you're going into head
voice so that is that feeling is you've
kind of transitioned right over yeah so
let's go a bit lower again and we'll
just try and remember that feeling
[Music]
yes keep that sound forward
you got me there that was it it wasn't a
great transition that was a transition
yeah that was it that wasn't like a big
old jump and as you can feel it you can
feel it kind of wobbles at first and the
boring answer to this is just going over
it oh yeah oh yeah this would be hours
of practice this would be but that's
that's a thing i've never achieved
before yeah like i've never
i felt that switch from one voice to the
other yes
oh yeah thank you
all right so so let's
let's give the producer two versions
okay let's do one that i'm i'm
comfortable with like let's let's keep
it in chest voice let's keep it low yeah
let's give one where where i can show
off a bit maybe and hit most of the
notes yes like give me the first chord
but i'm going to try and do it acapella
so we've got the the production
yes all right so okay so just your chill
yep you're relaxed keep that space it's
all down in down and down in chest voice
and this is all what i'm comfortable
with all right
[Music]
oh ho
i want to try something with you all
right okay okay so we're gonna grab a
singer's friend a straw you're gonna put
this in your bottle of water oh sorry
drop it on the floor which is not good
that's fine that's fine all right okay
so we're gonna put this this straw yep
in your water right give me like an uh
and you know
see how much air you're putting through
yeah
yeah i see that yeah
yeah that's a little too much yeah
you want it to be like boiling water
okay so you're gonna sing you're all
holy night
on an earth i was i was trying to power
through that wasn't it yes too much too
much
so you want as much air as the bubbles
uh can i get can i get the the
holy night
the stars are brightly shining
it is the night of our dear savior's
okay that was much better that felt much
more comfortable it's it's still like
it's not great but it's it felt more
comfortable yeah and that's a real
example of it's not how much effort you
put in yeah it's just like it's so
counterintuitive because we feel like
right i'm going to do this
i want to pavarotti it yeah yeah okay
but pavarotti you don't see him he's not
like oh you're like and a lot of that
even when you're watching rock stars is
performance all right it's not like
what's happening on the inside of their
body let's let's right let's give the
producer
something to deal with let's let's go up
like two octave one octave two octaves
whatever whatever
to the point where i'm gonna have to
[Music]
the stars are brightly shining
it is the night
it is the night of our dear savior's
birth
good luck whoever's
whoever's whoever the producer is
good luck
thank you so much tom my name is adam
neely i run a channel that explores what
music means and what it means to be a
musician he's gonna hate the high
version on the internet which is amazing
uh tom you're a brave man for embarking
upon this project so i salute you sir
hey tom how's it wow
yeah doing well looking forward to
seeing whatever it is you've you've done
with this because yeah
um i i don't think i gave you much to
work with
you actually there was one take of you
singing oh holy night that was pretty
good when you're singing in the chest
voice when you're down the octave
it actually it actually sounded pretty
nice um i figured we could listen to
uh just listen to it i'm gonna hate
every moment of this just just go for it
yeah of course okay okay so this is
without any of the stuff that i did to
it and i added a little bit of piano
background a little argument uh this is
this is what we have right here
oh holy night
the stars are brightly shining
[Music]
i i've just experienced i think like
full body cringe reaction my own voice
there but it is it is saved by
god just putting the the piano in the
background makes such a difference it i
i think it does honestly i mean i'm i'm
not you're i'm not you i i can i don't
have the same watching red at this point
but now but now with the magic of modern
music technology we can uh we can tune
it so this is uh slightly it's been
slightly tuned okay this is what it
sounds like
oh holy night
the stars are brightly
shining
it is the night
of our dear
savior's birth
i mean that's that's better
that that felt that felt better um yeah
it still sounds like me and i still feel
like
there's a lot of singing training i'd
need to to make that work as like having
i know it's still my voice i don't think
my voice is good enough to do to do
singing yet well i mean there was a few
things and uh when i was tuning it i
pointed this out we can like look at
actually how the notes are oh okay
are uh lying on the the tuning scale
right here this high note right here
this was perfect this is like when you
sing it it was perfect it was right
there the tone color i think you could
maybe improve with uh with vocal
training okay
so you've got the words for this now i
don't like what do you mean by tone
color
so when you're i'm i'm not a singer or a
singing coach but i've definitely worked
a lot with like tuning vocals um it's a
lot about resonance and placement of
vowels in other words shaping vowels in
your in your mouth
and you can see that you're doing a
vibrato right here uh like this up and
down that that warbling of the pitch and
you can see that it kind of uh
an ideal vibrato with an ideal vocal
control kind of looks like a sine wave
just up and down perfect around the
pitch yeah that's not um
it starts that way and towards the end
it opens up into a more controlled
vibrato which is great when you say so
that should be going in amplitude at the
same i'm trying to work out because
that's like the function of
well this is the frequency change yeah
exactly yeah and it should be
in a controlled vibrato controlled
vibrato normally goes alongside the
tempo or whatever the piece of music
you're singing or playing
um oh okay
mine was completely uncontrolled it's
just
i never i never even thought that that
was a thing singers could control
yeah that's that's something that uh you
spend a lot of time practicing being
able to control the vibrato that way wow
and just mix you know make it it makes
it feel more like you're connected to
the rhythm that you're singing and so
you're like you're like doing vibrato on
16th or 32nd notes or something like
that and hitting
more or less yeah you can control it
depending on what uh what the style of
music is um i mean i didn't even have a
metronome in the background so okay fair
enough no but the timing you still
there's still rhythm even if there isn't
a metronome going on i mean i'll take
i'll take the pitch i'll take matching
the pitch on that one but the rest
yeah yeah so one thing that i was
noticing when you're going when i was
going through it is at the ends of
phrases that's when the pitch got a
little bit a little bit waffly and
that's a thing with that comes from
breath support
being able to like control the ends and
the beginnings of notes
and that's something that's hard for
melodyne to actually correct for
but i did my best i think it i think it
sounds pretty good honestly
we should point out like autotune's like
a brand name here right this is right
this is melodyne this is pitch
correction is a thing like autotune's
the the title but yeah so and i i'm
guilty of this auto-tune is sometimes
used as a catch-all phrase for any kind
of pitch correction yeah um so sometimes
i i'll say i'm auto-tuning you but the
name of the program i'm using is
melodyne which is more of the industry
standard for this kind of pitch
correction auto-tune can do this but
auto-tune you normally associate with
that like t-pain effect the really
robotic effect i i think it's really
interesting though that like
even with melodyne and even with you
you've done this for for so long with so
many things
you can't turn an untrained voice into a
trained this is a this is this could go
out in a record
well uh i mean people try
like
youtubers out there with christmas
singles that people try but yeah well
there are other stages here i want to
emphasize that because if we were going
into a recording studio i could probably
or somebody who is more trained than me
could probably vocal coach you into uh
getting better and better takes and also
we could do something called vocal
comping which is record the same thing
many many times and then take the very
best bits from each recording and put
them together into like this
frankenstein take which is actually very
very common and honestly goes a longer
way to creating the feeling of a
professional recording or sounding like
a professional singer than just melodyne
so if you had melodyne and the practice
of comping going on here we could we
could put together something pretty
pretty i just need to sing every line 50
times and you would go oh i got i nailed
that note that time that note that time
exactly shook a load of piano and
production underneath a bit of reverb on
there and yeah okay yeah yeah
um so basically yeah i just need you to
sing this 51 more times
and we're good to go i never want to
hear this song again
having said that you've got the you've
got the head voice tape left yes okay
okay this is this is the head voice take
i'll i'll do it just to spare you i'll
do it without
taking the melodyne off oh no no no go
for it you might as well you might as
well okay because i haven't heard it
but i i haven't heard this
at all but like i've heard it when i
produced it but i haven't listened to it
back i i've got no idea what it's going
to sound like other than i remember the
voice not being good
okay fantastic so
yeah here we go so i added a little bit
of strings too just to you know have it
i like spring string sections
yeah
[Music]
that sounds like someone doing a bad
impression
of
like a 70 year old grandmother who can't
sing
that's appalling i oh okay right it's
amazing it's amazing but like you know
um
a lot a lot of singing a lot of music is
just like the confidence to do it
um and yeah yeah this is not that yeah
you are holding back tom give us give us
the jews
that's not music that's a war crime come
on
so okay uh this is with it with tuning
okay so i had to had to really spend
some time on it but yeah thank you thank
you for taking the time thanks for
listening to this so many times to make
that work that's
oh holy night
the stars are brightly shined
[Music]
no that was the fun part that's f that's
like yeah it's part of the arrangement
it's also still clearly someone singing
so far out about rugged
tone color is an important thing in
singing and you can't
you can't change that tone color is like
how all of the harmonics of the voice
come together uh and it
we don't have a good way of synthesizing
that yet to be able to correct for that
i'm sure technology will develop in the
next five to ten years to be able to
really go in and really edit vocals like
that but for right now we just we're not
there we're not there uh we can really
only correct for timing and pitch
and so
you know vocals are a lot in singing is
a lot more than just timing and pitch
there's you know there's musicality also
involved in it
um okay so then so that was
then oh yes of course there's a then
this is this is the this is the fun one
so um what i did this is the fun one
okay oh yeah i know they're all they're
all fun for me
they're all fun
um
so because you sang
it in the same key just down and off oh
no okay i could take the first one
of you singing in chest voice which i
thought was
was pretty good
and then i could
cut it up and then time align it to your
head voice version so now the
these are the two versions which are
aligned on top of one another and then i
took
that chest voice version and then i
doubled it a bunch of times alongside
all the doubles of all of the head voice
so long on this
i'm so sorry thank you
oh that was so fun and then uh and then
here's the sheet music for whatever
this is oh holy night the tom
coral edition i wrote in the cough and
all that just you know from outer side
just you know how do you know
i mean i know the answer to that now
you have a little x in time it was most
of it was in time so this is uh the full
the full version let me uh let's let's
listen to it um
let me just
do that do that do that
[Music]
good luck
there we go okay
merry christmas adam merry christmas tom
merry christmas